una visita urgente mientras las
tensiones diplomáticas entre madrid y
rabat siguen aumentando el presidente
del gobierno español pedro sánchez viajó
el martes a ceuta en el norte de
marruecos tras la entrada de un número
récord de emigrantes en el pequeño
enclave español alrededor de 8000
personas llegaron a ceuta en tan solo 48
horas sin que los guardias marroquíes lo
impidieran ya sea nadando o haciendo el
viaje en pequeñas embarcaciones y balsas
en esta imagen el ejército español rodea
a las personas que aún están en el agua
y las devuelve al mar a golpes un viaje
que merece la pena para estos migrantes
si no no hay trabajo así que no tenemos
dinero no hay dinero para mi casa para
mis hijos
los jóvenes de este país están asqueados
no hay trabajo no hay médicos no hay
hospitales no hay nada es casi un día
mujeres que dejaban a sus hijos en casa
a otros con sus bebés en brazos mientras
intentaban cruzar a nado era un caos
toque solo fosas parqueos aunque será en
vano para la mayoría el ministerio del
interior español dijo que la mitad de
los llegados de han sido devueltos a
marruecos a primera hora del martes
madrid convocó al embajador marrón
le he recordado que el control de las
fronteras ha sido y debe seguir siendo
la responsabilidad de españa y de
marruecos junto con el otro enclave
norteafricano de españa' melilla ceuta
tiene la única frontera terrestre de la
unión europea con áfrica lo que la
convierte en un imán para los migrantes
que buscan entrar en europa desde las
playas situadas a unos kilómetros al sur
en marruecos hasta ahora rabat ha
aceptado la devolución en caliente de
casi 5000 migrantes más de la mitad de
los que cruzaron la frontera en los
últimos dos días